hello everyone my name is magdalena
today it is my great pleasure to talk to
you about
deep learning aided drug discovery
before we start
i would like to
[Music]
tell a few words about the plan of
today's presentation
so at the beginning i would like to
discuss
some
things connected with
drug discovery
what is it
why
are we interested in it
and next i will
tell briefly about deep learning
and graph neural networks then i will
tell more about
tools that are used in deep learning
either drug discovery
i will present
a demonstration
some
implementations
and then i will
tell briefly about our model
that
aims to predict
molecular properties finally i will
conclude
my talk
so
before we begin i'd like to clarify the
process of drug discovery
so here you can see a target
and this is the object
in blue and
in general
let's say that this target is associated
with the
disease
and
um
and
yeah in real life uh this target is
often a protein
and now
a hemi a chemical compound which you can
see
in green
is a molecule that can cure the disease
or at least can help in the treatment
process
however
this
molecule
may have
undesirable properties
and
in general we would like to optimize
some properties or know that the given
molecule cannot be a drug because of
their
properties can be bad for people's
health
for instance the molecule may be toxic
and
yeah
and
finally
when we
know that the given molecule
is
okay in general
um
it can be
called a drug
and in general
drug discovery is a complicated
and systematic project spent over
from 10 to 15 years
which is a long journey for a drug
from invention to market in practice
meanwhile
due to the complexity of biological
systems
and a large number of experiments
drug discovery is prone to failure and
inherently is inherently expensive
to address these issues
of course many researchers proposed
various
computer-aided drug discovery methods
for small molecules
and
to to help in this process
and
there are
many different stages of drug discovery
and the earliest
stage is
uh for
clinical research
and then we have kid identification
and selection heat tool it optimization
uh clinical and we we
go to the clinical candidates
and despite the success in existing drug
discovery traditional
methods are mostly based on molecular
simulations techniques
which suffer from the huge computation
cost and time consuming
procedures and of course that limits its
application in
pharmaceutical industry
and
uh
yeah
as i said that the
chemical space is very large
we can say that
the number of molecules is
um
like 10 to the power of 60
yeah and
one of the
method
that is commonly used
is called virtual screening
visual screening is a computational
technique
used to predict potentially bioactive
chemical compounds which i will call
ligands here
and
these compounds
bind to a specific target which i showed
at the beginning
and
as i said
it is usually a protein receptor
or it can also be enzyme
and visual screening can substantially
speed up the drug discovery process to
reduce its significant cost
by reducing the time invested in
expensive experimental es
write our experimental verification
and as you can see uh
it consists of narrowing down an initial
large library of compounds to a
considerable smaller
final set of heat compounds which are
then tested experimentally in vitro to
confirm their biological activity
in both terms virtual screening
approaches can be categorized into two
classes ligand-based screens and
structure by screens
and a ligand-based screening
starts from
usually two-dimensional
or three-dimensional structure
of one or more already known ligands
and then searches a chemical library for
example that
in either a 2d or a free distance
and in contrast structure-based
screening
doesn't require a priori knowledge
of any ligands that bind to the target
protein
but instead
it involves in it involves
sequentially
um docking each member of the chemical
library against the 3d structure of the
target protein
and using a scoring function so-called
scoring function to evaluate the let's
say quality
of each model's protein ligand complex
and
the scoring function
is intuitively
meant to serve as
let's say proxy
for the expected strength
of a given protein ligand complex
and uh in general the
scoring function
is typically built upon either a
physics-based
force field
or an empirical function
or just a set of
knowledge based terms
and
yeah and
undoubtedly
a vast number of published models
are based on
traditional
molecular representations
and which are
used as the input to their machine
learning model
traditional machine learning models
and
here you can see an example of the
output of such algorithms
depending on the task
we can
say that
you know we work on regression or
classification
problem
and of course
to
handcrafted
representations
um
yes and um
of course
a vast
number of
published
models
are based on
this i representations as i said
but
uh first of all there is no clear
best traditional representation of
chemical compounds for machine learning
algorithms and
certain
representations may be better for
specific tasks
nevertheless existing traditional
molecular representations fall into
mainly two categories
um numerical molecular descriptors and
smiles
strings
and also
we have an
a representation called a graph approach
graph based approach because um
as you can see
a molecule can be intuitively seen as a
graph
yes
so
over the last few years deep learning
methods have made significant progress
on the numerous machine learning tasks
leading to a substantial improvement
of the state of the art in many areas of
research
they have also revolutionized
their way problems in chem informatics
are being solved
and compared with the conventional
molecular descriptor calculation
as you can see here a deep learning
based approach performs
so-called future learning
known as representation learning
and the main idea is to learn compact
and expressive representation
yeah
and
of course
a few examples of current work
on representation learning and its
application to chemistry
includes um such approaches as
convolutional
new networks on graphs
waves graph attention networks graph
neural networks with convolutional armor
filters and so on
however
satisfactory performance is generally
associated with a vast amount of high
quality
data available
and in practice the lack of labor data
in chemistry
that is caused by many factors
that include expensive experiments
and errors impedes the exploitation of
the full potential of representation
learning
and another vital aspect is the limited
structural
information
incorporated into current deep models
um as you may
see a molecule is not
only a set of
um atoms and bonds since it also
consists of the wires molecular
dependencies that are often mixed
yeah and however
a chemical compound
as
showed
previously
i
can be
naturally seen as a graph
with nodes corresponding to atoms and
edges that correspond to bonds
and of course
one may learn on molecule on a molecular
structure
and
viewing molecular structure as graph
data
leads to so-called graph neural networks
based architectures
um gnn
s
in short
and molecular graph enables to capture
the spatial connectivity of different
atoms and preserve molecular bonds which
amongst others bring real benefits
in consequence a large number of
ground-based neural networks
and models have been investigated
such as
passing neural networks
and convolutional networks or graph
attention networks
and
obviously there were success
successfully
learning molecular representation tasks
one advantage of graph representation
is that
it carries more structural information
and besides molecular graphs
as well as the subgraphs
could be directly mapped to
chemical structure and thus are highly
interpretable
which is very important
and of course
we have
quite a lot of
we have quite a lot of
tools
that are designed
to facilitate
the process of drug discovery
especially for deep learning
um the examples include
rdkit
um audi kid is just a collection of chem
informatics and machine learning
software
that is written in c plus plus and
python
another interesting
tool
is a
deep scam
this is a python deep learning library
for molecular machine learning and last
but not least
we have ddl library
and
ddl library is a high performance and
scalable
it sounds like yeah your mics may be a
little close it sounds a little ruffled
zoe
oh much better yeah for a second it
sounds like the sounds a little muffled
but i think you're better okay
very good so uh dpl is a framework
agnostic
uh so uh if a deep
graph model is a component of an
end-to-end application the rest of the
logics can be implemented in any major
framework such as python
apache
and so on
yes and of course we have also
numerous publicly available libraries
um they include campbell or pubchem
um
yes and
here
i would like to show you a
few lines of code that can be used to
um
to create to use a model one of the
models that is available
in this
framework
and
the model is called get
and
uh here you can see
example
an example how can we
use it to
create
uh
to to use the data
in this case we we want to
uh
work on
the data connected with toxicity
yes and then
we can
calculate
the specified
property
for the given molecule
so in general this is quite easy
uh to use it if you if you are able to
write a few lines of code in python
you can easily
use the available
functions
to work on
molecular datasets
and
yes
finally
i would like to tell a few words
about
my
recent work
so in my work which is a result of
my collaboration collaboration
with the university of vienna
we proposed a neural network
based architecture
that
overcomes the
aforementioned difficulties
so our architecture comprises of two
separate blocks
and either block aims to land an
expressive representation
from a given compound
the first block models a molecule as an
undirected graph
and the idea is to treat a molecule as a
graph with nodes corresponding to atoms
and edges corresponding to
bonds
and of course to learn
to learn a molecular
representation
the core part of this architecture is a
stack of attention layers
and followed by a fully connected layer
of clouds applied to form features from
molecular graphs
and the second block converts a molecule
into molecular fingerprints
then a deep learning algorithm is
adapted on the
future vectors
yeah and the output is returned
and
then as you can see here
uh the two final v2 vectors
uh are concatenated here and here
and we
we get
this representation
and
the final layer is actually a regression
or classification layer depending on the
needs
and it is used to estimate the output
as the property
value
and as it was mentioned our model
employs
two stacks of graph attention layers at
the first block
and the first stack aims at providing
atom embedding
while the second compute a chemical
compound embedding
and here in this approach a collection
of atomic and bond features
are proposed to capture
the detailed structure
property relationship information
um
yeah
and maybe
i will tell more about
the experiment
we have conducted
so we evaluated the performance of our
approach
on
numerous data sets from molecular here
molecule net is a publicly available
um
data set
yeah and
in general
[Music]
here
we randomly split data set into training
validation and test set
and
furthermore when we work on regression
task we use root mean squared arrow as
the performance metric
and
and as mentioned previously in order to
encode a graph one has to provide
provide
note features
and we call this step future extraction
and in this work we apply
12 types of features that cover
both atomic and bond features all
features are one-half encodings except
for formal charge radical electrons and
atomic mass which are real numbers
scaled to be on the same order of
magnitude
and a glance at results on the test set
reveals our method as the model with the
best performance
and for all three data sets
also
analysis of prediction quality
indicate that the maximum difference
between the experimental value and the
predicted one for a given compound
is not
large
moreover most of the structures are
different
and
it proves that our method can capture
the molecular information and doesn't
depend on the type of the
molecular
structure
yes and
to sum up we introduced an a method that
is based on a deep neural network
approach
and
our method can be used to predict
their biological and physical chemical
properties of small molecules
and our well-designed architecture
employs two separate blocks of
operations to learn the molecule
the molecules representation
and in the evaluation of our method with
the molecule net benchmark data sets
accurate prediction performance for
were achieved
and apart from that
it is
important
to note that
of course our method solves
one of the problems that can be
taken into consideration
but
there are a lot of
other tools available
for
drugs and discovery especially deep
learning i did drag discovery
and many of them are publicly available
thank you